l'homme qui va sans aucun doute devenir
le nouveau président algérien était très
jeune
un surdoué de la politique puisqu'il est
resté pendant 16 ans le ministre des
affaires étrangères de houari boumédiène
à 62 ans
abdelaziz bouteflika a aussi connu une
longue traversée du désert
il est aujourd'hui soutenu par le
pouvoir et par les militaires huguette
le scénario était pourtant bien huilé
soutenu par les militaires et le pouvoir
favoriser par les médias le candidat
bouteflika avancer tranquillement vers
la victoire mais leur très fière de ses
six rivaux a ruiné la stratégie de ce
fin politique et lui il le sera mais
sans l'onction démocratique tant
recherché je veux que le peuple algérien
se pendant avec les draps gang largué à
une majorité substantielle concurrents
puissent apporter les changements
nécessaires si le peuple algériens
voulaient autre chose je rentrais chez
moi
la conscience tromper j'aurais fait ce
que j'avais à faire
lycée ans abdelaziz bouteflika a rejoint
le maquis en 1956 il rencontre alors un
homme qui va bouleverser sa vie
houari boumédiène une amitié est née
elle ne se démentira jamais 1965
l'austère colonel boumédiène s'empare du
pouvoir son premier geste est de
rétablir bouteflika dans ses fonctions
de ministre des affaires étrangères
little big man comme on le surnomme a 28
ans et les coudées franches pour mener
une diplomatie active la france apprend
à négocier avec cet homme subtil mais
déterminé la consécration internationale
intervient en 74 il est élu à
l'unanimité président de l'assemblée
générale des nations unies mais la mort
en 78 de son ami houari boumédiène sonne
le glas du diplomate
écarté par les militaires condamnés pour
corruption
il entame une longue traversée du désert
en 94 les militaires en mal de candidats
le presse de se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle il décline la proposition
le temps de la réflexion
bouteflika attend le moment propice
aujourd'hui la victoire lui est acquise
mais c'est une victoire au goût amer
ce